[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture date a dit wolf
bonjour alors si vous aimez les romans
quand on commence la première page qu'on
peut lui lâché alors là vous allez être
servis puisque nous recevons jacques
expert bonjour jacques expert
bonjour bonjour vous vous présente pour
ceux qui vous connaîtraient pas encore
vous avez part si vous évitez avait
direction de grands médias comme m6
comme et paris première comme airtel
mais votre premier métier ses
journalistes et en tant que journaliste
vous êtes beaucoup intéressé aux faits
divers vous avez par exemple suivi la
sphère grégory vous êtes d'ailleurs ceux
qui la connaissent le mieux est votre
premier livre l'ont même s'intéresser à
l'homme qui a vécu passé le plus de
temps en prison
et puis vous avez fait un premier roman
qui s'appelait la femme du monstre vous
aura témoigné un petit peu sur ce qu
aurait pu être là la femme de fournir et
et puis ensuite toute une série de best
seller ce soir je vais tuer l'assassin
de mon fils dont l'adaptation à la
télévision d'ailleurs a connu un immense
succès de goutte d'eau dans lequel deux
jumeaux rendait impossible enquête
policière
hortense dont on va pouvoir voir de
l'adaptation à la télévision d'ailleurs
le 14 décembre prochain
je ne vais pas tous les citer mais ce
qui est intéressant ce sont des romans
dans lesquels nous intéressait beaucoup
à la manipulation et ce sont aussi des
romans ou des personnages sont pas hors
sol passé des personnages très proche de
nous qui pourraient être nos amis et
c'est d'ailleurs le cas un attique
dedans non plus fort qu'elle
tout à fait et bien alors le pitch oui
je vais jouer jouer pitch et puis je
pouvoir le faire en toute liberté
parce que c'est vrai que souvent dans
fais attention à ne pas tout spoil et
comme on dit en bon français mais alors
dans votre cas dans le cas de votre
roman jacques expert et bien on peut
justement dévoilé un certain nombre de
choses puisque dès le départ
eh bien vous faites du lecteur votre
complice alors j'y vais pour l'histoire
c'est s'il forme un couple en apparence
parfait avec patrie ils ont
tous les trois ils vont par dont trois
enfants et elle vient d'une famille
riche
ils n'ont aucun problème d'argent et lui
ont plusieurs d'être nommé numéro deux
d'une entreprise florissante à à
bordeaux mais au tout début du livre
eh bien on assiste à la mort de cécile
de sortie de son sommeil en pleine nuit
à reçoit avec ou très violent derrière
la tête et fait dévale les escaliers en
marbre et on va apprendre très vite qui
est coupable c'est je peux le dire
jacques expert non mais oui en fait une
manipulation france après midi je vous
ai couvert ses maris c'est marie et à
leur première question à vue si
l'enquêté était bien de bois voilà
et alors première question à vous poser
est bien est ce que dans ce livre ce qui
vous a le plus intéressé c'est de faire
le portrait d'un pervers manipulateur
lui at il enfin moi j'ai comme le disent
et patrice est quelque peu de temps j'y
suis pas mal de faits divers dans ma
carrière et ce qui est au ski et
intérêts sont maîtres dans les diverses
et pas le c'est pas le crime
je sais le criminel en fait on va vous
donner donc à rien à voir avec pour
livre mais la sphère johnatan d'aval
douce et of medicine etc
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est pas de
crime en lui-même
ces personnalités de l'assassin ces
liens qu'il crée avec ses beaux parents
c'est la personnalité des victimes est
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que six jeunes at elle n'aurait pas été
si dd je construis ce philibert n'aurait
pas fait la halle à la une de la presse
mais il a fait l affaire villemin aussi
y avait des personnages hors normes et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
m'intéresse dans mes romans salaires
dans tous mes romans c'est d'abord le la
victime le criminel
celui qui a commis l'acte défectueux qui
m'intéresse a priori parce que là la
personnalité est complexe elle est pas
simple mais on est aussi bien tous les
deux comme moi on n'est pas mannequin
contre côté totalement houta mauvais il
parle de sommes un peu noir en nous et
c'est ça qui est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est cette part cachée de l'individu
que j'essaie de mettre dans mes romans
et donc dans le cas précis sagitta
manipulateur pervers et mais c'est
l'homme qui m'intéresse et les relations
qui peuvent se nouer entre les individus
alors justement dans sept personnages il
ya donc ce patrick apparemment mari
modèle mais dont on va s'apercevoir
vicky qui collectionne les coquettes et
parmi ses conquêtes s'il ya une liaison
avec son assistante qui s'appelle rafael
et alors là il ya quelque chose de
formidable d une invention formidable
dans votre roman
c'est que c'est raphaël par amour va
quitter son mari bon ça ça arrive mais
elle va aussi quitter ses enfants et ça
s'est très très mal perçu dans l'opinion
une fable ou think it qui équipent
marion saab on peut comprendre clic et
de ses enfants
on comprend pas et donc peut-être que là
l'idée de cette femme des enfants qui
pourrait être une coupable idéal va
germer dans l'idée dé dans le cerveau
des policiers et peut-être aussi du
lecteur alors celles comme le dit le
bandeau de me coincer d'une manipulation
donc dans cette manipulation le
manipulateur pouce de cette femme à
l'extrême de ski mais elles peuvent
faire c'est abandonner ses enfants parce
qu'il sait que l'opinion publique va
forcément se retourner contre elles ans
ça fait partie de l'ue piège dans lequel
tombent avec par amour d'une certaine
façon elle est tellement amoureuse
qu'elle ait prêté tout et on peut dire
tout ça c'est pas tellement spolier le
livre parce que il la question ce qui va
le savoir qui a tué parce qu'on s'est
assez vite qui est l'auteur écrit mme la
question augure roman et qui va se poser
juste
20 c est ce qu elle va sortir de ce
piège ou est-ce que le manipulateur va
l'emporter et c est le fait d'avoir
quitté ses enfants qui est un acte le
plus terrible du directoire de mer qui
en plus aime ses enfants est une bonne
mère s'est fait partie d'eux et de
manipulation bah oui c'est ça c'est bon
et on disait à l'instant vous faites du
lecteur votre complice et en même temps
voulu faire dit vous lui faites vivre un
suspense qui est difficile à soutenir il
est difficile à soutenir parce que même
quand on est lecteur de romans noirs on
a envie quand même que le bon gagne
contre le méchant et ont dialogué ici
même avec tient le m l'auteur du
dictionnaire amoureux du polar il ya
quelques semaines et on avait comme ça
évoqué les questions de classification
des romans noirs donc on peut classer le
vôtre dans la catégorie roman
psychologique alors oui c'est exactement
la bonne bonne calme revenir au mans
c'est à dire encore une fois mais je
pense que ça tient souvent se pose la
question mais il y ait entre journaliste
et romancier va clairement le lien et
est assez ténue lors par le fait que
notre journaliste comme un écrivain
écrit après c'est le même travail et le
travail terrain les solitaires mais ce
qu'il de ce que j'ai mon expérience de
journaliste c'est que au delà des faits
que j'ai pu le suivre un tas de la fois
des univers et les événements en europe
de l'est a guère de slave i ended en
empathie qui rentrent en différents
endroits et dur était au niveau
psychologique au niveau de vos du
terrain s'est dotée vraiment des
expériences parfois extrêmement
douloureuse ce que j'ai rencontrés c'est
très bonne et sens en disant comme ça
mais c'est l'humanisme l'humanité c'est
l'humain
de plus extraordinaire et de pire et
c'est d'une certaine façon ce que je
mets dans mes romans donc effectivement
c'est des romans psychologiques qui se
nourrissent quand même d'une vraie
expérience ont fait une longue
expérience professionnelle mais qui
nourrit et doré vous revoilà justement
se dit roman psychologique quand on est
évidemment quand on me parle d'une
manipulation
on se dit eh ben les crimes et seydou sy
paille sait où il va or je crois et
c'est on va peut-être enfin par révéler
un secret de fabrication mais je crois
que quand vous commencez le roman vous
ne savez pas exactement comment il va
finir est-ce que vous pensez que pour
surprendre le lecteur faut d'abord que
vous surprenez vous même en écrivant la
réponse est oui je pense effectivement
que la femme de ce rebond de la semaine
du précédent mais de l'autre des tous
les rôles où je connais pas la fin art
sans connaître la semaine et même sans
faire le plein en fait c'est un plan de
l aventure et si mes romans ou une
qualité
on va dire c'est d'être à ses pêcheurs
en herbe content c'est fini un chapitre
on se dit tiens d amélie avec mes
ennemis je vais dormir puis quand même
je tiens encore un chapitre
supplémentaire et il le voit que moi
même je me mets en pêcheur mère de mes
propres de mes propres mains
faut dire que je me surprends moi même
et je vous assure quand je prends une
piste comme si tu introduis un
personnage je ne sais pas si ça sera une
bonne piste où une piste de série ou si
ça sera un personnage important et les
personnages se construisent ou se
déconstruisent au fur et à mesure et on
peut tu reviendras en arrière je
l'aurais en arrière qu'à la fin dans une
fois que j'ai trouvé ma faim et que je
sais comment le roman finir que je
décris tout bas je retravaille tout pour
que la faim le début et le déroulé au
volant de quatre ans et que le boss vie
pour rien comme ça mais je sais pas très
un peuple en qualifs pas et et le lever
et partir à l'aventuré pour sa plus
jouissif certaine façon c'est plus
dangereux mais c'est arrivé d'ailleurs
d'abord donner des intrigues que vous
aviez commencé et puis ça marche pas à
quoi ça peut nous arriver
les igas faut que nous il faut qu'on
écrit 200 panneaux steeple
le médecin l'a bouclé les plus notre vie
notre histoire il faut trouver l'année
vous trouver absolument la solution donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya un mouvement qui
s'appelle à dieu qui sortait il ya
quatre ou cinq grandes pierres
apparentes et j'avais écrit 200 pages
donc c'est quand même 150 s'est envolé
de dire qu'on va dire et je trouvais pas
ma faim tellement que je ne souhaitais
bloguer que j'ai pas les pales des tic
est mort a posé ses malles en commun et
c'est vrai ce que je vous raconte
business area peu près cette image
d'epinal c'est mon normand houde soir
que ça prenait vraiment la tête et que
j'ai trouvé la mécanique de faé partir
de là c'est génial d'abord entre bien
toutes les angoisses ou pas voir
s'éloigner
et il y en a qui y en avoir souvenir que
parfois c'est c'est un exercice man est
tous assez limité de me trouver parce
qu'elle trouvait une fin c'est après
tout c'est par là qu'il est plus
compliqué de trouver ça le plus
compliqué c'est de trouver le vin qui
soit cohérente qui soit la plus
percutant possible c'est un polar je
pense qu'il ya ya ya trois secrets pour
un collard en tout cas je m'en donnait 3
1 il faut une un début qui soit assez
interpellant annoncé ça généralement
tous les auteurs de polars savent le
faire deux jeunes femmes un peu qu'ils
laissent six ans le livre est réussie en
convenait pas que c'est que je réussis
tout mais en tout cas c'est des recettes
et le troisième pour moi dans mon cas
particulier c'est bien des chapitres
assez court j'aime bien les cheveux
courts qui donne adule du rythme du
dynamisme et qui justement contre quand
il est minuit et demi qu'on en reste
couchée situe à notre bien je veux lire
encore 3 par année
aujourd'hui je suis en fait trois ou
quatre petits chapitres supplémentaires
ça n'est pas exactement quand j'ai
décalé du plus fort plus fort qu'elle
nathalie très vite là je crois qu'on va
arriver à la fin de notre interview
mais je suis peut-être encore savoir une
de govou grande force dans votre livre
c'est qu'ils sont ancrés dans la vie
quotidienne et les protagonistes qu'on
rencontre on a l'impression dé connaître
en tunise élévatrices total voilà nos
voisins et vous connaissez très bien
aussi l'univers du du fait divers
et là aussi les faits divers vous l'avez
dit ce qui ne passionne plus sont ceux
qui sont proches de nous alors que cette
proximité là parlons beaucoup de passion
des français pour les faits divers
segel je crois qu'ici à cette passion
des français pour le fil d'hiver c'est
que dit ça peut pas forcément m'arriver
à moi mais la personne le type sympa on
salue tous les jours qu'ils vous aiment
éventuellement à jardiner ou à tous qui
vous rend service etc ou à bricoler si
ça se trouve c'est un monstre
vous avez souvent dit content quand un
pédophile et arrêté et c'est en
interroge et bazin désormais il est est
ce que je disais bonjour tous les matins
le mec il est envoyé bienne et ses
enfants à l'école
jamais on n'aurait imaginé on l'adorait
essai
c'est cette dualité qui est quand même
intéressante et je pense que si les
faits divers plaisent aux gens c'est que
ici je retrouve mon voisin c'est un
c'est un site un s commence à
avoir un peu peur de nathalie merci
beaucoup jacques expert sera pas donc
c'est plus fort qu'elle sait chez
calmann lévy et puis le 14 décembre sur
france 2 l'adaptation d'un autre de vos
romans
hortense et avec notamment catherine
jacob merci infiniment merci à vous
merci
[Musique]